He may follow the steps of the heavenly
teacher and listen to his voice as when
he taught on mountain and plain and sea.
He may dwell in this world in the
atmosphere of heaven, imparting to
earth's sorrowing and tempted ones,
thoughts of hope and longings for
holiness, himself, coming closer and
still closer into fellowship with the
unseen like him of old who walked with
God, drawing nearer and nearer the
threshold of the eternal world until the
portal shall open and he shall enter in.
He shall find himself no stranger. The
voices that will greet him are the
voices of the holy ones. Voices who
unseen will unearth his companion. And
so my good sister, I have no fancy
method. My method is brutal, bloody,
consistent repetition. Hello friends,
welcome back to this YouTube channel. We
all love how pastor Reniskit quotes the
scriptures from his head. Right? His
boldness to preach the scripture without
opening the Bible is is a standing
testament to the dedication and
commitment he puts in to memorize the
scripture. This lady asked Pastor
Rendeskit how he memorized the scripture
and how we can follow his steps and she
asks pastor Randy Skit to show some
examples on how pastor Randy Skit
memorizes the scriptures and the
response he provide to this lady will
really really enlighten our minds and
our hearts. Let's watch this video till
the end. Go ahead sister. So I'm asking
this question for a friend. Um you had
mentioned
>> uh how you memorize Bible text but can
you go into more detail on how or can
you even like give us an example on how
you memorize passages or even script uh
spirit of prophecy.
>> Okay. Uh I was let's say when I was
memorizing Revelation 16 what is found
in Revelation 16
this last place. [clears throat] If you
go to that chapter, because when you
memorize, you must know where each
individual verse is when you need it.
You can't be preaching, I need a verse
from Revelation 16. Let me recite the
whole verse, the whole chapter till I
get to the verse. You can't do that. You
have to know which where each verse is.
I realize plague number four is in verse
8. Tell me if I'm right.
Plague number five is in verse 10.
Plague number six, where do you think it
is?
>> Verse 12. Yes. And plague number seven.
Where do you think it is? 17. No. 17.
17. [laughter] 7. 17. And so those
became markers for me.
So I could find the plague. Now all I
had to do now was focus on the first
three. Are you with me? But four was in
verse 8. So you look at the structure of
the passage.
For instance, let's say when I was
working on Daniel 8, in the third year
of the reign of King Belshala
Belshazza, a vision appeared unto me,
even unto me, Daniel. After that which
appeared unto me at the first, so there
three unto me. So you look at that, you
okay, there are three unto me.
When you when I was memorized Genesis 5
and Adam lived 130 years and begat a son
in his own likeness after his image and
called his name Seth and all [snorts]
the days that Adam lived for 930 years
and he died. Now there is a there's a
pattern to all of the patriarchs in
Genesis 5. Once you get that pattern it
becomes easy to plug in the numbers. You
see and all the days of Methuselah were
96 and9 years and he died. All the days
of Lamech were 700 770 years and he
died. you you you see the formula and
you then plug in the numbers and that
comes along with of course constant
constant repetition with Ellen White
it's not quite the same way
you have to get as in the Bible as well
what is the individual thought there's a
beautiful passage in the education page
127 paragraph 1 with the word of God in
his hand every human being wherever his
lot in life may be cast may have such
companionship ship as he shall choose in
its pages. He may hold converse with the
noblest and best of the human race and
may listen to the voice of the eternal
as he speaks with men. As he studies and
meditates upon the themes into which the
angels desire to look, he may have their
companionship. He may follow the steps
of the heavenly teacher and listen to
his voice as when he taught on mountain
and plain and sea. He may dwell in this
world in the atmosphere of heaven,
imparting to earth's sorrowing and
tempted ones, thoughts of hope and
longings for holiness. Himself coming
closer and still closer into fellowship
with the unseen like him of old who
walked with God. Drawing nearer and
nearer the threshold of the eternal
world until the portal shall open and he
shall enter in. He shall find himself no
stranger. The voices that will greet him
are the voices of the holy ones. Voices
who unseen were on earth his companions.
Voices that here he learned to
distinguish and to love. He who through
the word of God has lived in fellowship
with heaven will find himself at home in
heaven's companionship. What was she
saying? I had to understand the spirit
of the passage of every sentence to
she's telling us you can hang out with
Bible characters
literally hang out with them by studying
the word of God and their life. Daniel,
Joseph, little cap, whomever, you can
hang out literally with Bible
characters. And by so doing, the effect
of their character will change you. So
that if you suddenly ended up in heaven,
you'd feel at home because you've been
custom hanging out with Moses and David
and Joseph, Elijah, and this is what
she's saying. And so once I got that
central message, one of the most
beautiful passages I've ever read in all
of Elaw's writing, then I looked at
every sentence.
And you have to forget each sentence.
And that's how I do it at LOL each
sentence. But again, it's over and over
and over and over writings. You cannot
escape constant repetition.
Everyone wants an easy way. There is no
easy way. You can't sleep with desire of
ages under your pillow and wake up in
the morning and know it. It doesn't work
like that. You have. But the more you do
it, the easier it becomes.
We're not willing to try. You know, you
try for a week, you memorize whatever
Genesis 1:1, and after two days, you
forget it and you give up in
discouragement. No, you say, "Look, I
will get this or I'll die or die
trying." You try and then your mind
becomes stronger and stronger. Education
page 123, paragraph 1. for the mind and
the soul as well as for the body. It is
God's law that strength is acquired by
effort. It is exercise that strengthens
both in the gym and here.
You don't build muscles going to the gym
and doing one rep. [clears throat]
You don't build muscles by lifting
pillows. Are you following me? You have
to lift weights. You sweat, you grunt,
you groan, you collapse on the floor.
But the muscles start to grow
spiritually. You've got to do the same
thing. Are you with me? Don't give up.
Remember, this is for your spiritual
growth. This is for your spiritual
strength. Your defense against Satan is
thus sayth the Lord at any age.
And so, my good sister, I have no fancy
method. My method is brutal, bloody,
consistent repetition.
You know what there's some passages when
I was working on them the names of they
say where these people get these names
from Jesus.
You know Genesis 14 came to pass in the
days of Amriel king of Shina Ariel king
of Kedle king of Elam and Tidal king of
nations that these made war with Bera
king of Sodom with Bersa king of
Gomorrah. Shinab king of Admma Shamiba
king of Zaboam and the king of Ba which
is Zor. All these were joined together
in the veil of Sidim which is the salt
sea. 12 years they served Kedoma and in
the 13th year they rebelled and in the
14th year came and the kings that were
with him and smought the rafaims in
ashoth carname and the zuzims in ham and
the emms in shave kiraame. Now you've
got to go over that all the time all the
time. All the time take medication to
get it because it it drives you nuts.
But you say God I'll die. I have to get
this.
I have to get it. And to my amazement,
it comes naturally. Then again, Abraham
took a wife. Her name was Catura. And
she bear him Zimran and Jockshan and
Maidan and Midian and Ishbach and Shua.
Abraham had six more boys beside Isaac
and Ishmael. Genesis 25. Six more boys.
I had to go over those names. Go over
those names. You know, Esau had 12 sons.
Esau. Yeah. Yes. Esau. And I had to
all the time. All the time. All the
time. All the time. All the time. These
strange funny name. You get into
Nhemiah. Oh, you talk about strange
names.
But practice truly makes perfect. I was
in South Africa many years ago. Uh, a
member of the church was formerly a
professional golfer. And he told me
every day he would drive the ball 600
times
to drive it, to perfect the the action.
600 times. I read way Kobe Bryant and
Michael Jordan, they would shoot a
thousand jump shot.
Mhm.
You might miss 800, but they kept
shooting.
You have to apply this to God's word.
In Mark chapter 8, Jesus told the
disciples, "I must go to Jerusalem,
suffer, die, rise again." In Mark 9, he
said, "I must go to Jerusalem, suffer,
die, rise again." In Mark 10, he tells
them the same thing. They never got it
immediately.
You have to tell them, tell them, tell
them.
Repetition
also understanding what the verse is
saying and a willingness to live by what
you learn.
But I'm telling you again, if you
practice, if you try, you will become
better at it. You'll be shocked how
quickly. There's a young there's a young
lady in Zambia.
She got my number somehow. I don't know
how. text me
this kid I so happy to have your number
how can I memorize I said just just try
you're in college just try she started
memorizing chapters
>> sending me the recordings and just
delight just I'm just delighted to
listen to those recording John 17 John
this you know she's just chapters
[laughter]
it's a family in a I hope they're not
listening to this I'll be crucified with
a smile on their faces I the mother of
that family had me started memorizing
working at Proverbs got through the
first 10 chapter. Now Proverbs is a
challenge because each verse does not
necessarily follow or connect to the
next. She was up to chapter 10 in
Proverbs.
There's a little boy in Botswana
memorized all of Revelation.
There's another little boy in the family
sent me an audio of him. He was in a
bathroom taking a shower. He's about
five. But all he ever hears is hymns and
the Bible because they live in the
country and the sound of birds and
streams. That's all he hears. So that's
all he can say. And he was in a shower.
He was taking a shower and he was
preaching. And Romans 12:1 says, "I
beseech you, dear friend. He's
preaching. He's preaching, washing him."
And the mother recorded him. He didn't
know. And she sent it to me.
>> And I just smiled. And he had memorized
Romans.
>> I said he memorized Romans.
>> Amen. He was five or six. His other
brother memorized Daniel.
Children are born with a mind that
absorbs like a sponge. We just have to
make sure they absorb the right because
they will learn fast.
We have to give them the right exposure.
But we still have that mind. Our minds
were made to learn forever. Try apply
your mind and let your mind be revived.
Try with God's word. The writings of
Ellen White.